alors les amis nous sommes nous sommes
en direct il se trouve on va être très
sincère avec vous on a un petit problème
technique aujourd'hui David sellers
c'est la réalisation un petit problème
technique ouais un peu en galère de
jingle vous allez vite vous en rendre
compte ce que je peux vous dire non mais
je rigole pas
voilà donc là vous pouvez pas rater vous
dites ce que vous pensez de votre
médiocrité technique aujourd'hui ou
médiocrité tout court n'hésitez pas il y
a eu pour renforcer son mariage
une américaine à vous donner le saint à
son mari est-ce que vous avez vu ça
c'est incroyable tous les coups pour
leur petites habitudes bah regardez
je ne vois pas ce qu'il y a de mal à
allaiter mon mari
on m'a dit qu'il pouvait boire d'autres
lait parce que boire le lait d'une
personne qu'on connaît les gens trouvent
ça bizarre
mais je voulais en parler pour que les
autres qui le font ne se sentent pas
seuls de devenir acteur non même pas non
j'ai pas dit ça
[Musique]
pas envie de